ti marcellin nadeau porte parole du
mouvement nous paie plats dont on
rappelle le slogan le mode horde et en
nouveauté m'enerve oui voilà alors vous
êtes réunis le 3 décembre dernier pour
dans la perspective des prochaines
échéances électorales
alors on va commencer par l'élection
présidentielle qui précède les élections
législatives vous avez pris une position
alors pas encore très tranchées on va
dire mais en tout cas vous indiquez à
l'issue de cette assemblée générale que
vous entendez prendre une part active au
débat de l'élection présidentielle est
également votre volonté de barrer la
route au candidat de droite et d'extrême
droite
absolument c'est à dieu que il faut déjà
aussi qu'un petit peu la dynamique nos
peuples à comment nous avons pu aboutir
certain nombre de positions c'est
d'abord dans les secteurs des militants
discuté plusieurs points de vue se sont
exprimé des positions et émerger et à la
suite d'une synthèse qui nous a été
présentée par nos différents référent de
section nous avons donc pris un système
d'orientation
s'agissant des présidentielles et
effectivement la dynamique nos peuples a
est composée bien sûr de place et un
ensemble de militants il ne s'agit pas
d'un conglomérat de partis ou de je ne
sais quelle alliance on se sent avant
tout des militants mais nous savons que
ces militants apparaît militante bien
sûr appartiennent à différents courants
et parmi ces courants il y en a qui sont
pour participent aux élections
présidentielles françaises il y en a qui
sont pas favorables à cette
participation
et puis parmi ceux qui participent qui
soit dit principe est bon plusieurs
candidats ont la faveur des uns et des
autres restent donc c'est pour cette
raison que nous avons décidé
effectivement de laisser nos militantes
militants et lecteurs et lectrices et
sympathisants de sympathisants libres de
leur choix
mais nous avons surtout voulu mettre en
exergue la nécessité de faire barrage
sans aucune hésitation non seulement à
l'extrême droite fascisante cette
fâcheuse fait qui se développe de façon
dangereuse en europe bien sûr qui a des
conséquences une autre caraïbes nous
reprenons la relation à nouveau voisin à
nos frères et soeurs de la cabine mais
qui a aussi des conséquences par rapport
à nos frères et soeurs qui
vivant en france et en europe mais
j'attire l'attention des martiniquais le
l'extrême droite française et européenne
n'est pas porteuse d'une idéologie banal
anodine c'est une idéologie dangereuse
qu'il faut absolument combattre et
aucune sorte de concession ne sera faite
à cette idéologie
après à bien sur la droite mais on voit
bien que la droite à travers notamment
le projet de celui qui a été choisi dans
les premières de droite je parle de
françois fillon une droite qui
s'alignent de plus en plus sur les
thèses extrémistes du front national à
la fois dans le rejet dans le rejet de
l'autre dans l'exclusion dans les
solutions néolibérale outrancière qui
porteront atteinte inévitablement aux
acquis sociaux et aux conquêtes aussi
démocratique s'agissant par les
injections notamment des lits dès lors
la part active que vous entendez prendre
dans ce débat de l'élection
présidentielle en france
est-ce qu'elle va au-delà de ce que vous
venez d'expliquer un barrer la route
je reprends vos propos candidat de
droite et de centre droite mais est ce
que ça alors vous avez dit que
effectivement au sein de nou pep là il y
en a qui seraient prêts à soutenir des
candidats bon on comprend plutôt à
gauche de l'échiquier politique
même à gauche de la gauche justement
est-ce que ça peut aller d'après ce
qu'on comprend à demi mot non ce sera
peut-être pas le cas mais ce que ça peut
aller à un soutien plus ou moins affiché
un voire même un appel à voter pour un
candidat de gauche ou à la gauche de la
gauche jean luc mélenchon est passé il
ya quelques jours est ce que vous l'avez
écouté vous l'avez rencontré l'intérêt
pour cette candidature par exemple moi
je pense que c'est une des candidatures
qui peuvent représenter une alternative
progressiste tout ce qui se trame en
france par rapport jeudi au renoncement
du social-libéralisme par rapport aux
aux dérapages de la droite vers
l'extrême droite et à la réalité
justement de de la montée
de l'extrême droite mais je crois que
bon j'ai quelques réserves quand même
par rapport à mélenchon sur la question
du droit des peuples à disposer
d'eux-mêmes bon il parle de métropole de
façon bon moi j'ai quelques risques
maintenant il ya peut-être des camarades
qui feront le choix de mélenchon c'est
leur liberté de nous mais ne fait pas le
mouvement dit à aucun candidat camarades
les amis seront libres de choisir le
candidat qu'ils veulent par contre
sociaux et vous est ce que vous pourriez
vous déclarez à titre personnel ça c'est
l'anti ce fait si je devais le faire
j'ai quand même merde une fraîcheur aux
écologistes ou le pensait bien que ce
serait plutôt joyeux que j'adore mes
préférences mais maintenant je n'ai pas
encore pris de position mais cannes où
je représente nos peuples a et la
position de nos peuples est de dire
clairement que nous ne soutenons et nous
soutiendrons aucun candidat de façon
précise mais nous organiserons des
bokantaj pour éclairer le peuple
martiniquais pour éclairer l'opinion
martiniquais sur la nécessité de refuser
la droite et l'extrême droite s'effondre
pour vous c'est il faut il faut quand
même voter il faut que l'électorat aux
martiniquais non seulement s'intéresse
mais votent pour les présidentielles ou
alors il faut sans humour c'est une
discussion complexe je resterai que les
posies le positionnement des gens qui
disent est ce qu'il faut vraiment
participer à ces élections comme je
respecte le positionnement des gens qui
disent il faut pas anticiper avec en
reprenant ce qui constitue le socle de
valeurs de nos peuples a dont je
pourrais dire que je suis plutôt neutre
dans ce débat ce que je dis que je
répète je suis totalement en phase avec
l'assemblée générale de nos peuples a il
faut surtout insister sur la nécessité
d' éclairer les martiniquais sur le fait
de ne pas commettre l'irréparable à dire
faire confiance à l'extrême d'accord
pour pour conclure cette séquence
de l'élection présidentielle autrement
dit vous n'allez pas non plus appelé à
participer à la primaire de la gauche à
la belle alliance populaire la recharge
de candidats devront pas partie à des
méthodes un peu plat qui souhaitent le
faire c'est leur liberté
mais pour ne pas nous à nos peuples à
nous n'appelons pas les militants à
participer à quelques primaire c'est le
libertador le faire alors vous êtes
dubitatif aussi ça veut dire que ça
soulève le doute chez vous sur l'intérêt
l'utilité de des élections sénatoriales
alors là vous vous indiquer que aux
élections sénatoriales parce qu'il ya
les législatives et puis ensuite l'année
prochaine il y aura le renouvellement le
renouvellement partiel du sénat français
alors non nous peuple va pas présenter
de candidats pour ces élections là parce
que ce sont les grands électeurs ça veut
dire les élus politiques on sait d'une
cip aux conseillers territoriaux
parlementaires dont vous-même qui qui
votait désigné alors il y aura 2 1 deux
sénateurs a désigné pour pour la
martinique
êtes-vous dit dubitatif sur ces
élections sénatoriales il a déjà qu'il
faut éclairer aussi là c'est fondamental
on en parle dans des élections pendant
les compétitions interpersonnelles de
gens et cetera sans qu'il y ait de base
idéologique véritablement s'en expliquer
ces croix le sénat fait fondamentalement
je ne crois pas que ça soit l'assemblée
la plus démocratique
bon nous à nous peuple en général nous
sommes pour une démocratie de proximité
participative et je crois pas que ce
système bicaméral correspondent bien à
nos valeurs fondamentales mambo mais
au-delà de ça je pense que l'ibpt
heureusement je dirais je voterai aux
sénatoriales mais je voterai en fonction
aussi des candidats
sus à partir d'une de nos traits vers
référentiel il s'agissait de vérifier il
s'agira de vérifier et bien que les
candidats aux sénatoriales et bien ne
feront pas ne seront pas les relais des
politiques que nous dénonçons néo
libérale autoritaire ou de repli
identitaire français en tout cas le
sénat c'est le deuxième outil législatif
quand même même si c'est pas le bleu
le celui qui prédomine en quelque sorte
le plus prééminent mais il contribue
quand même à faire des lois en france le
sommet bien sûr voilà je suis
parlementaire est quasiment le même
qu'en mai nous de notre point de vue de
martinique et ce qui est important c'est
de voir quel est l'outil le plus
efficace pour nous et quel est l'outil
qui se rapproche plus justement de de la
possibilité d'être une sorte de chambre
de résonance de caisse de résonance des
revendique parce que c'est ça on va aux
élections pourquoi pas pour se faire
plaisir pas pour occuper des postes mais
pour être le rôle est fondamentalement
émet des aspirations mais aussi des
revendications du peuple des catégories
défavorisées des gens qui veulent faire
avancer exemple le pays martinique dans
son développement autocentré etc
c'est ça qui est fondamental non c'est
pas aller aux élections pour aller aux
élections c'est pas aller pour occuper
des places des postes c'est aller pour
servir les intérêts du peuple et donc
nous nous essayons de voir quelle est
l'outil le plus adapté à cette nécessité
d'avoir des caisses de réseaux de
résonance du peuple au niveau plus haut
niveau s'il le faut dans quelques
secondes 7h25 sur l'antenne de
martinique première on aime arsenal à 2
ans à oka dit au pape parole de du
mouvement nous peuple acquis qui va
alors là c'est le gros morceau l'année
prochaine pour nous peuple acquis par
contre entend participer aux élections
législatives
peut-être surf et même sur votre score
votre forme de percer qu'il y a eu lors
des élections territoriales
en martinique il ya un an donc voila et
et vous entendez figurer dans les quatre
circonscriptions législatives c'est de
ce qu'ils font rappeler au maintien
quasiment un ticket on a tendance à
l'oublier c'est que nous peuple à la
suite donc des élections pour la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
est quand même la quatrième force
politique de la martinique quatrième
force politique il faut pas l'oublier
donc nous avons le devoir à partir de là
et bien de continuer effectivement à
diffuser le message fondamental que nous
avons pu diffuser pour ces élections de
la ctr va continuer à le faire et nous
pensons effectivement que après une
analyse et il ya eu des débats
intéressants il y avait des gens qui
étaient contre il ya des gens qui
étaient peau etc
mais à partir d'une analyse
on pensé qu'il était utile que nous
soyons présents dans le cadre de ces
élections pour développer nos idées et
puis pour effectivement essayé de gamme
et que des des candidatures témoignage
pour développer les idées ou est-ce que
vous aurez vraiment des projets enfin
bon voilà s'agit d'élire des députés
et bien sûr vous savez bien que nous
sommes l'une des rares organisations à
présent temps ne peut plus clairement un
projet politique pour le pays
mais c'est le même projet c'est le même
projet que nous déclinons à chaque
élection avec des objectifs clairs et ce
projet qu'elle était allée justement au
niveau de l'assemblée nationale
française pour poser la question des
leviers des leviers qu'il faut à ce pays
pour se développer des leviers qu'il
faut par exemple sur la question sociale
moi j'ai vu dans des marchés des
personnes âgées de plus de 70 ans qui
avait une pension de retraite modique et
qu'ils devaient travailler encore à 70
ans et plus pour essayer d'améliorer
leur ordinaire pour essayer de survivre
ça n'est pas normal
eh bien nous disons alors si les gens
votent fillon justement et s'ils veulent
pour des députés de droite y compris en
martinique
parce qu'il ya des gens qui ont beau
visage ici et mais ce sont ces gens là
qui seront le relais dans l'assemblée
nationale française de politique
antisociale scélérates et au détriment
des martiniquaises et martiniquais les
plus modestes singulièrement des
personnes âgées
il faut que les personnes âgées le
comprennent et ça nous le diront et puis
à les leviers qu'on peut mettre en place
pour être dans une logique d'une
économie autocentré effectivement il
faut protéger les petites entreprises
martic
il faut protéger la production agricole
martiniquaise mais c'est tout ça ça me
trouver menacée par des lois c'est déjà
bien
c'est une pièce siècle à base juridique
et légale qu'elle a su aussi une
question de santé publique parce que
l'alimentation a des conséquences sur
notre bien-être
quand on a vu tout le débat sur la
question du taux de sucre dans les
aliments quand on a vu que mon regard
des gens puissent jouer il faut être
dans un groupe parlementaire mais je
suis désolé
lurel il était dans un groupe
parlementaire mais sa fameuse loi sur le
taux de sucre dans les aliments ben elle
a eu du mal mais par contre nous serons
aussi et c'est fondamental nous appuyer
sur des réseaux militants d'élus
écologistes par exemple ou à gauche de
la gauche pour porter dans l'intérêt du
peuple martiniquais un certain nombre de
revendications alors marcellin nadeau
donc
vous avez annoncé que vous serez
présidents des quatre circonscriptions
vous n'avez pas encore dit quelle sont
quels seront les candidats
alors évidemment ce sera peut-être plus
facile ou moins difficile dans certaines
circonscriptions que d'autres notamment
on prend l'exemple du nord puisque vous
êtes le maire du prêcheur bon il ya de
grandes chances que vous soyez le le
candidat de nos peuples a dans la
circonscription du du nord mais pour les
autres bons la bataille va être quand
même assez difficile c'est pas le même
type de scrutin quand même que le
scrutin de liste de 12 décembre 2015 non
c'est pas des sondages mais ce que je
veux dire et non je n'y ai non non pas
du tout mais c'est glacé uninominal saas
apporte un peu quand même si vous voyez
ce que je veux dire il faut déjà il faut
voir les candidats que nous allons
présenter
je crois que parmi les militants de nos
peuples à une ancienne zone de militants
qui ont une certaine notoriété
bon voilà donné deux répondeur en partie
voire même interrogation
moi je suis soûl je serai soumis comme
tous les autres militants et bien au
choix des militants de ces coeurs ce
sont dans les secteurs que déjà il
faudra vérifier les modalités on vient
vous un candidat à la candidature pour
le nord oui je suis non de la
candidature mais ça ne veut pas dire que
je serai candidat vous savez dans
certaines parties a eu des surprises si
je me réfère à g qui s'est passé au
niveau des verts en france ne
s'attendait pas à bourges à dos 1
donc on s'attendait à voir la l'ancienne
ministre du logement etc
il faut faire très attention je crois
que nous ce que nous voulons c'est que
les militants s'expriment et qu'ils
fassent le choix nous faisons et nous le
disons le pari de l'intelligence
collective et je veux revenir aussi sur
le processus qui nous mène à décider
quand nous avons pris la décision de
notre positionnement respectif sur
chacune des élections
eh bien il n'y a pas eu de vote parce
qu'on a pas eu besoin de vote
c'est pas parce qu'on a un chef tout
puissant qui décide à la place d'emile
tente non c'est parce que nous avons eu
un débat fort ni animé est au bout de ce
débat on aboutit à des conclusions et
non on n'a même pas eu besoin de voter
parce qu'on a trouvé un consensus à
bercy ça la démocratie au pour sensuelle
pour conclure nous essayons de
promouvoir pour conclure je m'adresse là
haut au plus particulièrement aux mères
du prêcheur en quelques mots vraiment
des nouvelles du chantier du pont au
prêcheur
est-ce qu'il sera livré comme prévu
l'année prochaine en 2017 allons le pont
avance fondamentalement alors je ne sais
pas s'il sera livrée à toujours aussi
après un certain nombre d'aléas
v mais je crois que ça avance et les
prochains sont très fiers de l'open
d'ailleurs vive le pont c'était merci
marcellin nadeau